on your new album um there's a song
called smiling
and i love it so much
like it's because it's not i know a lot
of people will say oh that's for people
in the limelight it's not that's for
people in
any vocation like any any part of your
life you can be having that moment to
where it's like
i'm going through so much but i guess
i'll keep smiling since that's what
everyone's expecting and i and they're
and i'm supposed to be
fine you know and especially as women
too right
i mean we're we're sort of archetypally
almost it's almost like a demand to be
that
hearth overseeing nurturing which is
normal for us in our bodies but we're
also applying ourselves in this whole
yang world too so for me it's it's it's
all these different archetypes that i
love being the teacher the mom the
artist the activists the
outspoken the you know the channeler the
all these different archetypes and just
the hats you know
i mean i'm talking to you you of all
people know the hats of mom and then
producer and then so just going through
all these different roles
and because of the sensitivity and the
empath qualities i'm just so much more
responsible for making sure i can take
breaks even if it's
hiding in a bathroom i mean i you know
carrying earplugs with me
don't tell anybody no no i'm wearing
them right now
i'm reading your wedding i'm actually
not listening to you
no that's so true i i literally i that's
i i've had this conversation with
someone very close to me and i'm like
i'm not trying to be
rude like when i pull out the earbuds
and like the music i literally sometimes
i'm not even playing anything
right i just want silence i just want a
moment to where i'm not being talked at
or i don't feel like i'm having to
engage because i feel like
not just not our jobs all jobs i feel
like we're a society
a society of oneness like yes to be off
i mean our nervous systems were not
meant to be in in cortisol
24 7 and we're actually chronic stress
in the way that we're all experiencing
yeah it's like yeah it's constant i know
i know
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going